i woke up once and my world was never
ever the same
and that's when i realized that i was
physically
and mentally addicted to it
[Music]
let's go through the first time you took
carol
yeah it was in 1997
and yeah i met up with
someone i knew i'm not going to say a
friend you know like an associate
a substance that i guess straight away
was heroin was put on the foil
and i was showing how to smoke that
it numbed me to the point of
i felt totally totally content
i reckon it's sort of going back to
being in
the mother's womb i should think where
nothing bothers you
nothing phases you nothing worries you
everything is just
easy blissful you're almost invincible
you start chasing that buzz
again you want that feeling and i would
say
that i didn't run out of heroin at all
for the first four months and then after
about
four yeah between four and five months i
woke up once and my world was never
ever the same and that's when i realized
that
i was physically and mentally addicted
to it
from the moment you awake
to the moment you go to sleep you are
thinking about
scoring the next bit of heroin you're
then also thinking where is the money
coming from
after that i've nicked washing machines
that have been
outside when you've seen the people get
them off the lorries on the little
trolleys i've walked off with one of
those before i've gone in and just
grabbed
armfuls of designer clothes
designer handbags anything basically you
know because i knew different people
fences they're called um
that could they would buy anything that
i got
anything at all i served nine prison
sentences
either for drive mode disqualified or
for shoplifting
i went through some nasty nasty rattles
in there in there when you're sort of
detoxing because back then they didn't
give you anything
to help you sort of come off the most
they'd give you was an aspirin and
that's not going to do anything if you
can imagine
your intestines and your bones
feeling like they are on fire one minute
and then being frozen the next
you've got horrible sweat you're being
sick
you get diarrhea you cannot keep still
you've got the twitches
your mind is just trying to switch off
you can't sleep it's
just the worst feeling the worst
experience i've
ever gone through that's when you start
thinking
i am not in control of this and then
because i wasn't properly clean when i
came out
within an hour i was taking heroin again
i now weigh anything between 14 to 14
and a half stone
going back then my lowest was just under
8 stone
because you don't eat food you're not
staying hydrated
i don't know really how the body
functions just running on that
about 2006 i
decided that that being a heroin addict
was always going to be my life
you just go along with it rather than
beating yourself up because you
you want to get clean and you can't you
throw your hands oh well this is my life
you know i'll do this and i'll just
carry on
in 2008 i was involved in
a robbery i was robbed and i thought i'd
been punched three times in the back
and i'd been um stabbed i remember
laying down in the dirt
and i could taste ash and dirt on my
tongue
and out of all the years that had gone
past before when i didn't care because i
mean i've overdosed many times
at that moment
something was just in me
that this life was so very precious and
there was
more to life
i was hospitalized for that it was a
hard time
but from that point
i never ever have touched any illicit
drugs since then
all i can liken it to is if you get a
computer
and you reset it to factory settings so
you wipe off
everything that there is in there and
you've got a blank space to work with
that's what it was like for me you know
i didn't know
what tastes i like i didn't know what
smells i liked i didn't know
what i liked i didn't know what genre of
music i didn't know
anything you are literally reset to
factory settings
and that was an incredibly tough time as
well and even now
almost 12 years on you know i might get
a smell
of something or i'll hear a piece of
music
and and it's like it rekindles a memory
that had almost been erased when we
haven't got
security in our life and we're missing
something anybody
could become an addict
in september of this year
i will be 12 years clean from heroin
which is massive because my addiction
was 11 years
long so i'd have been clean longer now
than what i had the addiction
an addiction is a negative if you say
addiction it's always seen as a negative
whereas on the flip side of that you can
have a passion
which is the same drive but if you say a
passion it becomes a positive
since turning my life around i've become
a multiply published author
i'm a qualified nutritionist
i'm a passionate advocate for
animal rights and veganism and i also
join on an animal sanctuary
i've been one of the lucky ones i've
been through all of that
abused my body to such an extent
i'm still here and i've got no regrets
about what i've done who i am what i do
now because
to have regrets we cannot change it so
you have to
embrace the good and the bad in your
life and just cherish this life
you